vamos a hacer un pequeño repaso de qué
era la tasa de fondos federales creo que
queda un poquito grueso la tasa de
fondos federales y luego pasaremos a un
concepto similar que a lo mejor hayas
escuchado en contextos similares y este
es la tasa de descuento hasta la tasa de
fondos federales y la tasa de descuento
ahora están relacionados y más o menos
se mueven de la mano sin embargo su
implementación sí es muy distinta va
entonces la tasa de fondos federales es
una tasa objetivo es la tasa objetivo
con la cual el banco federal quiere que
los bancos se presten entre sí
entonces supongamos que tenemos cierta
ya no voy a dibujar las hojas de balance
supongamos que tenemos al banco 1 y está
el banco 1 y este de acá es el banco
número 2
supongamos que este banco tiene un
excedente de reservas eso usualmente lo
pintó de verde pero lo voy a pintar con
amarillo así para que nos dé nostalgia
la época del patrón oro para entonces
supongamos que tiene un excedente de
reservas y que el banco número 2 las
necesita va y no se digamos que el banco
no está dispuesto a prestarle al banco
número 2 si el banco número 2 le paga
una tasa de interés por noche de 6%
bueno 6% anual claro va ahora no se el
banco de la reserva puede decir sabes
que eso está por arriba de nuestro
objetivo queremos que los bancos se
prestan entre sí por un interés más bajo
de esta forma vamos a realizar
operaciones en el mercado abierto para
que disminuya esta tasa de interés las
mecánicas ya las vimos pero va otra vez
dibujamos la hoja de balance del banco
federal la voy a poner por acá en color
rosa mexicano
chin creo que quedó muy delgada
ahí está no está es la herramienta
incorrecta
a estas horas y ahí está la mitad por
acá queda la otra mitad
entonces digamos que estos son los
activos actuales del banco federal
dentro de algunos vídeos vamos a ver una
hoja de balance real del banco de
reserva de eeuu por el momento nos
quedamos con esta esto de aquí son los
activos actuales del banco de la reserva
federal sus pasivos sus pasivos son un
poco más pequeños que sus activos y por
tanto tienen tantito capital en el
capital del banco de la reserva es un
poco distinto otros capitales pues nada
más se obtiene dividendos por él no nos
vamos a meter en los detalles pero el
mecanismo que usa el banco federal para
hacer estas operaciones en el mercado
abierto es esencialmente imprimir dinero
entonces la reserva federal- lo que va a
hacer es crear algunas notas o bien un
poco de reservas entonces estas son
notas de la reserva federal o bien como
las conocemos como billetes de pesos que
están en tu cartera o bien las cosas que
pueden ser convertidas en billetes toda
la información de tu cuenta bancaria que
está guardada en bits y bytes en algún
lugar bueno esto no se pueden crear de
la nada pues tienen un pasivo
correspondiente y el pasivo
correspondiente en este caso serían
notas federales
notas federales pendientes va entonces
esto es un pasivo que dice que la gente
puede venir a pedir su dinero ahora
aunque estas notas federales hayan sido
deja de ponerlas con amarillo aunque
estas notas federales hayan sido
emitidas por el banco de la reserva en
el fondo están respaldadas por todo el
crédito y la fe que te otorga el
gobierno federal ya platicamos un poco
de eso pero sigamos con la mecánica lo
que hace el banco es tomar esos billetes
de pesos que acaba de imprimir y luego
va a comprar pagarés federales de
cualquier persona del mundo podría ser
yo o no se podría hacer algunos de mis
abuelos o incluso podría ser algunos de
estos bancos entonces no sé digamos que
ahorita ya alguien que tiene uno de
estos pagarés supongamos que soy yo
entonces yo tengo un pagaré de federal
ok entonces tengo un pagaré federal y lo
que hace el banco de la reserva no sé
mejor digamos que yo tengo un montón de
pagarés hoy así el hombre más rico del
país o no sé tal vez soy china china
compre un montón de pagarés de eeuu
entonces compran el pagaré de modo que
esté activo ya no son billetes
ahora es un pagaré federal deja le
escribo pagaré federal y luego qué pasó
conmigo pues yo ya no tengo ese pagaré
ese ya se lo vendí quién sabe a quién
sólo sé que se lo vendí a alguna persona
del mercado abierto que pudo haber sido
mi tía o la tuya pero resulta que en
este caso fue el banco federal bueno a
cambio yo obtuve reservas obtuve dinero
vaya ahorita lo que obtuve son billetes
de pesos que es una nota del banco
federal luego lo que voy a hacer con
esos billetes que obtuve es que los voy
a depositar en algún banco no sé digamos
que tengo este dinero ya sé supongamos
que tengo varias cuentas bancarias y que
entonces parte del dinero lo voy a
depositar en una cuenta bancaria que
tengo en este banco y que otro tanto lo
voy a depositar en el banco de acá
entonces qué sucede ahora este banco
tiene más billetes para prestar y este
otro banco necesita menos billetes otra
forma de decirlo es que la demanda
disminuyó este banco necesita menos la
demanda de este banco disminuyó y la
oferta del otro banco aumentó
sabemos que si algo se necesita menos
pero la gente lo ofrece más entonces el
precio para adquirir o pedir prestado
ese bien tiene que disminuir en este
caso este banco tiene más y éste lo
necesita menos y por tanto pues ve este
banco no está dispuesto a pagar 6% por
el préstamo pero este otro está
desesperado por prestar para que le
paguen algo de interés entonces este
banco va a disminuir el interés que
cobra este va a disminuir lo que está
dispuesto a aceptar y quizás baje a 5%
si el banco de reserva todavía no está
de acuerdo entonces puede hacer otras
compraventas para ajustar la tasa vaya
incluso pueden hacer la operación
contraria si por alguna extraña razón la
tasa bajará mucho como a 3% y al banco
de la reserva federal no le gusta nada
esto porque quiere que sea más alta la
tasa objetivo con la cual los bancos se
prestan entre sí entonces pueden hacer
justo lo opuesto pueden tomar este
pagaré esto ya que es un pagaré y luego
lo venden lo venden en donde pues en el
mercado abierto otra vez digamos que se
lo venden a este monito de por acá
entonces éste monito pues tiene algunos
billetes de pesos no sabes qué mejor voy
a poner sus billetes pues en alguna de
sus cuentas bancarias
supongamos que tiene tantos por acá y
otros tantos por acá va entonces cuando
el banco federal le venda este pagaré a
este bonito lo que va a ser este monito
es una transferencia electrónica o bien
va a escribir un cheque pero en
cualquier caso estas reservas van a
desaparecer estas reservas regresan al
banco federal al regresar cancelan el
pasivo de notas pendientes y después del
dinero básicamente desaparece en el
sistema bancario lo que sucede es que la
demanda de reservas aumenta porque claro
ahora hay menos reservas en el sistema
la demanda aumenta y la oferta va a
disminuir también causado por la
disminución de reservas pero ahora este
banco va a decir wow ahora tengo menos
para prestar así que tengo que cobrar
más interés y este otro banco como está
desesperado por pedir prestado va a
pagar más interés y por tanto la tasa
aumenta digamos a 4% ahora toda esta
idea funciona siempre y cuando estemos
en un mundo en el cual los bancos estén
dispuestos a prestarse a alguna tasa por
ejemplo este banco puede decir pues
estoy dispuesto a prestarle a este otro
porque sé que al día siguiente me va a
pagar esto es sólo una cuestión de
oferta y demanda de hecho estos
préstamos como son por sólo unas noches
suelen ser
y seguros pero qué sucedería en un mundo
en el que déjame volver a dibujar los
dos bancos creo que es sobre dibuje en
el dibujo anterior aquí está el banco
número uno
este es el banco número 2
el banco número 1 tiene más reservas y
el banco 2 tiene menos reservas de hecho
necesita reservas y digamos que por
alguna razón la gente está espantada del
banco 2 y entonces empiezan a sacar sus
reservas
y como ya platicamos estos bancos no
tienen dinero para satisfacer todos los
depósitos de hecho déjame dibujar la
hoja de balance del banco número 2
supongamos que esta es la hoja de
balance del banco número 2
tienen tienen un poquito de capital
ojalá por acá tienen algunos depósitos
supongamos que todo esto de aquí es son
depósitos tienen algunos depósitos
también pues tienen que tener algo en
reservas esto de aquí sería un activo
estas reservas dependen del requisito de
reserva pero vaya tienen algo de
reservas ya sabes en caso de que la
gente quiera sacar un poco de dinero de
sus cuentas de cheques y el resto son
otro tipo de activos justo el banco hace
dinero teniendo más interés por sus
activos que por su pasivo bajo como
dijimos este banco pues empieza a poner
un poco débil la gente empieza a
desconfiar de él y entonces los clientes
empiezan a sacar su dinero así van al
cajero sacan sus billetes y no se lo
meten a otro banco más seguro o lo
guardan en su colchón sale entonces el
banco se empieza a preocupar porque
empieza a tener falta de liquidez dice
pues si a lo mejor si esta cantidad de
personas quiere su dinero yo puedo
pagarles pero luego viene alguien más y
con eso se me agotan mis reservas y
entonces ahora si estoy en líos porque
cuando venga alguien más
su dinero pues se va a armar un pánico
tremendo no le puedo decir sabes que no
tengo tu dinero ahorita porque si le
digo eso entonces vamos a tener una
crisis bancaria enorme en la cual todo
el mundo va a retirar su dinero y voy a
tener una crisis de liquidez en una
situación normal y le diría al banco uno
necesito un poco de dinero y justo como
en la primera mitad del vídeo este banco
va a prestar le va a prestar reservas y
luego a cambio va a obtener interés pero
qué pasaría si este banco también está
espantado del banco número 2
dice uff este cuate está metidísimo en
problemas de liquidez no sé cómo están
sus activos a lo mejor están
disminuyendo no sé por qué hizo muchos
préstamos hipotecarios malos yo no le
quiero prestar ese banco y entonces este
banco se hace un paria del sistema
bancario nadie le quiere prestar por
otro lado pues a nadie le conviene que
ignoremos la situación de este banco por
qué pues supongamos que él no le paga a
uno de sus clientes y este es uno de los
puntos débiles de la banca de reserva
fraccionaria tan solo tener un eslabón
débil en la cadena puede hacer que se
pierda la confianza en todo el sistema
tal vez este banco era el único y
responsable de todo el sistema bancario
y no sé cuando el primero de sus
clientes no pueda sacar su dinero a lo
mejor le llama la prensa les cuenta que
no hay dinero en los bancos y genera un
retiro masivo por no saber qué bancos
son buenos y cuáles no es terrible para
prevenir esto el banco federal tiene
algo que se llama la ventanilla de
descuento déjame dibujo la hoja de
balance del banco federal la ventanilla
de descuento es prácticamente un
prestamista
de urgencia un prestamista para los
bancos va entonces supongamos que hay
una cierta tasa de fondos federales que
está no sé en 6 por ciento de modo que
usualmente los bancos se prestan a 6%
pero supongamos que esto ya no funcionó
por esta razón este banco está súper
desesperado y entonces lo que puede
hacer es ir a la reserva federal puede
ir a la reserva federal y tomar prestado
directamente de la reserva federal una
vez más esto de acá son los activos de
la reserva federal activos estos son
pasivos el capital de la reserva federal
y la reserva federal en esta situación
lo que va a hacer es imprimir billetes
notas de la reserva federal
que tiene un pasivo de notas pendientes
y esos billetes se los van a prestar a
este banco entonces los billetes se los
presta al banco a cambio este banco
tiene que dejar algo en garantía para el
banco de la reserva federal no sé
supongamos que por aquí tenía algunos
activos que son difíciles de vender o
bien que no podía vender rápido y
entonces los deja como garantía a esto
se le conoce como contratos de recompra
y esencialmente es garantizar un
préstamo después voy a hacer un vídeo
más a fondo de qué se trata pero la
perspectiva general es que este banco
está tan mal que nadie le quiere prestar
de modo que la tasa de fondos federales
no importa de modo que tiene que acudir
a la ventanilla de descuentos del banco
federal como un prestamista de urgencia
al interés que paga por realizar este
préstamo a esa tasa se le conoce como la
tasa de descuento va entonces es la tasa
que le pagó un banco a la reserva
federal por un préstamo cuando no puede
pedirle prestado a otro banco en general
la tasa de descuento suele ser suele ser
mayor a no de hecho siempre es mayor
pues no queremos que la gente o sea si
la tasa de descuento fuera menor
entonces los bancos siempre preferirían
y he prestado al banco federal en vez de
esto preferimos que se presten entre sí
en próximos vídeos vamos a ver que en
tiempos difíciles esto se usa mucho más
históricamente la tasa de descuento ha
estado un poco arriba de la de fondos
federales para fomentar los préstamos
entre particulares pero en los últimos
años pues disminuyó la separación y casi
llega a cero después nos metemos en más
detalle pero una vez más es una
diferencia clave cuando el banco de la
reserva habla de ajustar tasas
usualmente habla de la tasa de fondos
federales después en consecuencia la
tasa de descuento se mueve de la mano
pero siempre va a ser mayor que el
objetivo esta es una tasa para préstamos
de urgencia esta otra es para préstamos
normalitos así del día a día entre
particulares para asegurar que todos
tengan las reservas que necesitan bueno
nos vemos